et pour en débattre nous sommes avec
david olivier reverdy secrétaire
national adjoint du syndicat alliance
police bonsoir david olivier reverdy
merci d'être avec nous à vos côtés
antoine ne l'est au mans responsable de
la communication numérique de la france
insoumise bonsoir à vous aussi antoine
noël et oman merci d'être là alors après
les propos d' emmanuel macron
reconnaissant l'existence des contrôles
au faciès on réponse de syndicats de
police dont le vôtre un david olivier
reverdy alliance 1 ont appelé à ne plus
faire de contrôle réponse de l'exécutif
un bobo de la sécurité en janvier pour
fixer une réforme ça répond à vos
attentes vous vous sentez lâché par le
président david olivier reverdy
non mais en fait je suis rom et
l'annoncent de du président
d'aujourd'hui si on la remet dans le
contexte
permettez-nous de douter de sa
s'inquiètent de sa sincérité
quelques jours après des annonces
fracassantes contre la police dans le
média brut pensant faire plaisir à une
jeunesse à laquelle il s'adressait
il a en fait fustiger la police
nationale il a fustigé les cent
cinquante mille fonctionnaires de police
les cent mille gendarmes qui composent
ce pays donc il nous a fusillé sur place
pour faire plaisir il a fait du en même
temps il a voulu faire plaisir aux
jeunes en même temps faire la police au
final il a fait plaisir à personne
il a fait du ni l'un ni l'autre et ce ni
l'un ni l'autre aujourd'hui fait que les
policiers sont dans la rue partout sur
le territoire pas seulement dans le 94
comme votre reporter l'a montré mais
également en province dans toutes les
villes de france
il y aura des actions willy a déjà des
actions qui sont entamées à l'initiative
du syndicat alliance police nationale
parce qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut accepter
des propos d'un président de la
république qui est censé être au dessus
de la mêlée qui est censé prendre de la
hauteur et aujourd'hui il s'est comporté
comme un un vaste citoyens engagés et il
a oublié qu'ils étaient prises en la
république
alors on va ré écouter à cette petite
phrase emmanuel macron qui a mis le feu
aux poudres commentaires faits par le
président on le rappelle lors de son
interview aux médias brut la semaine
dernière
aujourd'hui quand on a une couleur de
peau qui n'est pas blanche on est
beaucoup plus contrôlés on est identifié
comme un facteur de problème et c'est
insoutenable
le président qui reconnaît donc certains
contrôles d'identité ne sont pas
toujours légitimes en quelque sorte ça
va dans votre sens
ou à la france insoumise antoine aller
au mans écoutez c'est pas une question
de le reconnaître c'est une question ce
sont des faits il ya on a en moyenne 20
fois plus de chances de se faire
contrôler dans ce pays quand on est noir
ou arabe donc c'est un fait établi par
ailleurs c'est inefficace du point de
vue concret puisque ça a été mis en
place le récépissé de contrôle
d'identité que nous demandons et pour
lequel nous avons d'ailleurs déposé une
proposition de loi
ça a été mis en place dans une ville
d'espagne et on constate son efficacité
puisque les contrôles inutiles ont
baissé de 75% et les contrôles qui mène
effectivement un contrôle d'un délit ou
d'un problème qui est posé augmente en
réalité de freins sont multipliés par
quatre donc premièrement c'est un
problème qui est clairement constaté
dans le pays et par énormément de gens
et en particulier si vous si vous si
vous avez vu les les reportages qui a
été fait aujourd'hui sur justement les
actions qui sont menées par alliance
police mais par aussi d'autres syndicats
de police sur ces contrôles au faciès
qui demande aux gens est ce que c'est un
problème que vous constatez les gens
répondent oui
donc au bout d'un moment monsieur on
peut dire enfin vous pouvez dire ce que
vous voulez mais clairement c'est un
problème que les gens constatent vivent
effectivement ils ne vivent pas quand
ils sont blancs puisque les contrôles au
faciès ça n'arrive pas quand on est
blanc mais c'est un problème qui est
constaté et ça pose un problème
extrêmement grave pour notre pays
puisque la république et doit envoyer le
message et notamment les gens qui ont
l'uniforme avec le drapeau tricolore sur
les pôles doivent envoyer un message qui
est celui de l'égalité entre les
citoyens là ce n'est pas ce que vivent
un certain nombre de nos compatriotes et
ça pose un problème majeur à mon avis
dans notre pays donc je pense qu'on
devrait pouvoir trouver un moyen de le
faire il est assez simple c'est la mise
en place du récépissé de contrôle
d'identité c'est ainsi un moyen
extrêmement simple ça réglerait le
problème et j'ai vraiment du mal à
comprendre pourquoi votre syndicat
s'oppose à la mise en place de cette
mesure à david olivier reverdy pour la
réponse
alors deux choses la premier fait c'est
vrai il ya une chose qui est établie
c'est la france a soumise par
l'intermédiaire de de monsieur mélenchon
on se caractérise par son anti flics
aujourd'hui non ce qui concerne la
police et monsieur mélenchon a pu le
répété à de nombreuses reprises devant
les caméras et de partout où il peut oui
il peut s'exprimer il l'a encore fait ce
nouveau à l'encontre du syndicat
alliance police nationale
donc c'est l'anti flic primaire de
monsieur mélenchon mais pas tous comme
ça vous s'est massée devant le siège de
la frontière l'important c'est que
j'invite ce monsieur présent sur le plat
sur sur le direct avec moi a constaté
les plaintes les plaines des victimes
lorsque des victimes font des fonds de
déposent des plaintes et signalent des
signalements sur les individus auteurs
des plaintes
vous prenez ces plaintes là et après
vous travaillez avec donc sachez qu'une
chose monsieur c'est que la délinquance
à la police et l débit la police la
délinquance est celle que les victimes
du signal et qu'aujourd'hui la police
monsieur la police parce qu'on y croit
c'est dans l'intense lorsque nous lisez
moi laissez moi finir et la police la
délinquance lorsque la police doit faire
des contrôles d'identité dans certains
quartiers où la mixité sociale n'existe
pas et où l'a dit les difficultés sont
ceux de ces quartiers là
la police y rentrer effet ces contrôles
et bien évidemment c'est facile de nous
taxer de racisme donc je trouve avec des
allégations extrêmement lisse et
républicaine dans ce pays antoine et aux
morts pour la réponse essayez pas parler
en même temps sinon on va pas vous
comprendre déjà qu'on est sur skype
merci le coc bible je suis je suis
d'accord mais enfin bon quand quand mon
interlocuteur parlant continuer raconte
un certain nombre de mensonges je veux y
revenir
nous n'avons jamais été anti flics et
d'ailleurs j'en veux pour preuve que
nous sommes
le mouvement qui a déposé qui a demandé
à ce que soit déposé une commission d'
enquête sur les suicides de policiers
parce que nous savons que c'est
difficile le métier de policier et je ne
comprends pas pourquoi votre syndicale
n'a pas soutenu par ailleurs vous dites
que la france insoumise serais content
le syndicat alliance mais c'est votre
syndic un monsieur qui est venu
manifester devant le siège
deux cas appelé à manifester devant le
siège de la france info news propos de
mélenchon vie mais parce que ado est là
et le renier par monsieur mélenchon
tient des propos aussi vous les assumez
pas ne les assume pas ce droit douanier
je ne renie absolument pas les propos de
jean-luc mélenchon s'étaient sur la
question des barbares du comportement
barbare et depuis nous avons été rejoint
par un certain nombre de personnes et
que je vous ai méprisés mois confie
d'organisations internationales
mais forcément monsieur parce que quand
un policier menace un parlementaire et
ne respecte pas un parlementaire alors
que le parlementaire si les objections
de la police rim que vous n'êtes pas au
dessus des lois monsieur et quand un
parlementaire donne mais un
parlementaire alors je vais vous
apprendre quelque chose mais un
parlementaire a le droit de se rendre où
il veut quand il veut
voilà ça c'est la loi monsieur c'est
vous ne vous ne la connaissez pas c'est
un gros problème que les policiers ne
connaissent pas la loi mais on n'empêche
pas un parlementaire de se rendre
quelque part voilà ne se sont pas rendus
sur la perquisition de jean luc
mélenchon effectivement sans commission
on l'imaginé antoine aller au mans oui
mais quand un parlementaire veut se
rendre quelque part il y as droit et
particulièrement quand c'est le siège de
son organisation et particulièrement
quand une autre organisation a déjà été
perquisitionnés le matin et qu'on est au
courant du fait de cette édition sous
l'eau ce n'est pas le sujet de messieurs
nous a effectivement indre non je
voudrais je voudrais répondre à ce qui a
été dit nous n'avons jamais été anti
flics nous signalons des problèmes et
quand on voit l'interpellation par
exemple de monsieur éclair qui s'est
passé récemment certains s'éloignent de
débats antoine et au mans parce qu'on
est fait sur le bobo de la sécurité mais
mais je vous en prie alesi effectivement
si vous voulez sécurité après après l
affaire est claire je vous l'accordé les
i éloigne pas du départ monsieur macron
à cette technique systématique qui
consiste dès lors qu'il ya un problème
dans notre pays a renvoyé à beauvau à
ségur un bientôt on aura un rivoli des
riches peut-être mais à chaque fois
qu'il ya un problème il nous renvoie
vers à un supposé sommet sûr sûr sûr ce
qui va sur ce qui va décider
mais moi je je je je constate que dans
notre pays il ya des gens qui subissent
des contrôles qui sont des contrôles au
faciès
je constate qu'on a des images qui nous
montrent
certaines interpellations qui sont
extrêmement violentes comme celle de
monsieur est clair et je rappelle que la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen que vous n'allez pas me dire que
c'est pas la république la déclaration
des droits de l'homme et du citoyen
parce que c'est quand même elle quand on
était à l'origine dit que quand on
interpelle quelqu'un il est présumé
innocent et que tout excès dans son
interpellation doit être durement
sanctionnés par la loi donc dans ce cas
là ce sont les policiers qui ne
respectent pas la déclaration des droits
de l'homme ce sont les policiers qui
doivent être durement sanctionnés par la
loi et pas monsieur est clair qu'ils le
sont monsieur ils le sont car vous
parvenir à se bourrer de la sécurité
aussitôt annoncée par le chef de l'état
aussitôt communiquer sur les réseaux
sociaux regarder le tout étant de votre
patron le patron de la police du
ministre de l'intérieur ce matin gérald
armen le bout de la sécurité annoncées
par le président de la république et la
première pierre de la grande loi de
programmation de la sécurité intérieure
tous les forces de l'ordre mérite depuis
longtemps quand gérald darmanin couteau
dithyrambique un david olivier reverdy
mais à quoi sert un beauvau de la
sécurité finalement on peut se poser la
question alors que le ministère a rendu
il ya quelques semaines un livret blanc
sur la sécurité intérieure comment vous
percevez cette réaction joyeuse de la
part de gérald darmanin bon gérald
darmanin est peut-être obligé d'avoir
cette réaction joyeuses parties fait
partie du gouvernement de monsieur
macron ou en attendant c'est vrai qu'on
n'est pas satisfait par ce bout de la
sécurité là parce que il y vient comme
un cheveu sur la soupe pour essayer de
faire oublier les propos de monsieur
macron donc c'est vrai que nous on
espère revenir sur les problématiques
qui sont les nôtres à savoir et qu'on
puisse créer un observatoire de la
réponse pénale
cet observatoire de la réponse pénale
c'est à 20 à savoir les peines encourues
les peines prononcées qu'on puisse
savoir ce qui se passe réellement dans
la justice qu'on puisse protéger les
policiers dans ce pays parce
qu'aujourd'hui on n'est pas protégé
on demande à ce que le droit à notre
droit à l'image est notre droit au
respect de notre vie privée soit aussi
respecter on demande en fait de la
considération considération qu'on n'a
pas et qu'on n'a pas eu et qu'on a plus
avec avec monsieur macron depuis ses
dernières déclarations
donc il ya toi ton taf sujets qui sont
sur la place aujourd'hui
qui sont les nôtres depuis longtemps
longtemps parce que la police longtemps
subi une décrépitude lente mais
inexorable et il est très clair
qu'aujourd'hui lancé un bourreau de la
sécurité comme ça au milieu de nulle
part pour essayer de nous faire rentrer
dans nos commissariats parce
qu'aujourd'hui je vous le rappelle les
policiers sont dehors
les policiers exercent leur métier avec
minutie pour montrer à la population que
nous sommes dignes d'être respectés et
que les propos de monsieur là monsieur
macron ont mis le feu aux poudres d'une
profession qui est déjà vous l'avez
rappelé extrêmement touchée très
durement touchée antoine est allé au
mans le mode la fao le la fin pour vous
justement emmanuel macron qu'ils
voulaient apaiser un petit peu ces
tensions entre la police et une certaine
partie peut-être de la population à ce
que c'était la bonne idée je pense que
monsieur macron n'y parviendra pas parce
que il a peur des syndicats policiers et
il a peur notamment du syndicat alliance
qui lui met la pression en allant
manifester devant l'elysée de temps en
temps je pense qu'il faut effectivement
refonder la police dans notre pays mais
la refonder en prenant globalement
l'intégralité de ses missions faut
savoir qu'actuellement 56% des activités
sur le terrain des policiers ça consiste
à contrôler des gens qui ont des
boulettes de shit donc franchement je
pense qu'aucun policier pas vous
monsieur non plus ne s'est engagé dans
la police pour faire autre chose et
c'était la population mais plus risquées
mais pour les yeux juste je suis le
monsieur je suis exactement entre humble
je suis si vous me laissez finir je suis
exactement en train de vous dire que je
pense que la police a mieux à faire que
de contrôler des boulette de shit je
pense qu'on devrait utiliser nos forces
de police
effectivement en renforçant leurs
enseignements de humains pour faire face
aux menaces terroristes notamment mais
pas seulement aussi à la délinquance
financière aux gens qui sont des
délinquants en col blanc qu'on l'ait le
courir je vais finir 2e
je vais vous dire je vais vous dire une
chose il ya actuellement sept mille
policiers de la bac et y en a que 5000
qui font de l'est ce qu'on appelle la
police judiciaire qui est justement
chargé de faire le reste donc lutte
contre le proxénétisme lutte contre la
délinquance financière était en moi je
propose c'est de la boxe vous pas
judicieux je suis en train de vous lire
vous ne serez pas sont sur la voie
publique ne sont pas une monsieur
judiciaire ou 10 pouces et si vous
écoutiez plutôt que de parler en continu
je suis en train de vous dire que quand
il ya 7000 policiers pour la bague d'un
côté et 5000 de l'autre pour faire des
choses que je considère bien plus utile
que faire du flagrant délit sur des
boulettes
j'ai pas seul bien 520000 judiciaire
pour pis ça serait quand même bien plus
utile en arriver je sais plus judicieux
absolument incroyable vous voyez qu'en
est il quand on quand on parle
d'agressivité dans la police vous en
êtes une cape ann en antoine et au
moment où baissant même si vous avez eu
je pense que vous avez autant parler
l'un et l'autre sincèrement mais j'avais
déjà fait des mesures intéressantes à
proposer je pense que monsieur net n'est
pas là pour faire des contraventions sur
du c'ur du du confinement
on en est à 255 milles contravention ça
représente 34 millions d'euros qui sont
prises aux poches des français ça sera
jean rouger d'un prochain débat entre or
antoine et au mans avec grand plaisir
merci en tout cas à vous et merci à
david olivier reverdy qui était venu
donc débattre sur le bobo de la sécurité
on n'en fera pas de vous re est invité
pour parler de ces mesures intéressantes
merci à vous entraîner au mans